although they're often electric
on-screen kisses aren't always planned
actors can surprise their co-stars with
a kiss during a scene for any number of
reasons from the tender to the funny to
the deeply controversial here are a few
on-screen kisses that were never
supposed to happen found in translation
one of lost in translations most iconic
scenes revolves around the tender
moments shared at the end of the movie
between Scarlett Johansson's Charlotte
and Bill Murray's character Bob during
filming Murray famously whispered
something in Johansson's ear that
neither actor has revealed the ensuing
kiss wasn't planned either
when asked about the scene director
Sofia Coppola told The Daily Beast I
remember sometimes Murray would spring
things on Johansson and it was fun to
get her reaction sparking anger during
stranger things twos season finale Lucas
and newcomer max share a kiss at their
school's winter dance in an episode of
the after-show series beyond stranger
things say desync who played max
explained that the kiss was a surprise
and that showrunners matt and ross
duffer sprang it on her the day of
filming Sadie you ready for the kiss
Nick what no no that's not in the script
okay that's not happening Ross duffer
had previously joked with Cink about her
kissing her co-star Caleb McLaughlin and
the idea had stressed her out so much
that he decided to have it happen for
real it was a decision which sparked
outrage online in wake of the
controversy Cink told The Wrap that she
had always felt comfortable on set
saying the duffer brothers always create
a comfortable space and if I felt
uncomfortable with anything I wouldn't
have done it anyways it's great I can't
imagine without it thank you a last kiss
Luke and Leia's scene towards the end of
the last Jedi is arguably one of the
movie's finest moments it's an exchange
which carries extra weight considering
carrie fisher's tragic passing only
months after filming ended the scene is
punctuated by her forehead kiss from
Luke to Leia which was improvised on
Mark Hamill's part was just spontaneous
and a really momentous for me because
Luke was saying goodbye to his sister
forever Hamill has been unable to watch
the scene since she'll be forever missed
and she's irreplaceable Woody's crush
after the home release of the Hunger
Games Mockingjay part 2 woody harrelson
told Entertainment Tonight that his
on-screen kiss with Elizabeth Banks had
nothing to do with the script she didn't
know I was even going to do it and I
just kissed her
Harrelson later told The Associated
Press I personally always wanted to kiss
her I don't know if it was the right
thing to do and although Harrelson
denied knowing it the AP's reporter
claims she'd heard that banks
intentionally flub takes during the
scene so she could keep locking lips
with Harrelson
Krakens snakes and stunt doubles thanks
to the logistical realities of filming a
television show an unplanned kiss
between two actors can often involve
more people than initially intended
that's what happened after Game of
Thrones actors Gemma Weiland and Indira
Varma improvised a kiss between their
characters Yara Greyjoy and Al arias and
they can be seen I think you don't need
a protector this moment takes place on a
ship just prior to an attack by
antagonist euron greyjoy Wieland's back
was injured at the time however and
since she couldn't perform all of her
stunts her double was brought in to
replace her and also had to kiss Varma
Varma told Entertainment Weekly that I
had to start kissing this four stunt
double and she was so terrified I don't
think she'd ever been put in that
situation before she's used to falling
over and being attacked and all the
stunts but to be kissed by an actress
was a bit beyond her Pratt finds away
according to Bryce Dallas Howard the
kiss between her character Claire and
Chris Pratt's Owen was never in the
script for Jurassic world
she told out magazine we had shot the
scene in the way that it was written
there was no kiss and then on the last
day that happened what you see in the
movie the movie's director Colin
Trevorrow however has since revealed
that it wasn't entirely spontaneous he
took Pratt aside and suggested he kiss
Howard but never told her on Jurassic
world's commentary he explained the idea
was we're just going to have Chris Pratt
surprise Howard in front of 200 people
and that's the tape that's in the movie
office romance during the season 3
premiere of The Office Steve Kerr else
character Michael learns that his
employee Oscar played by Oscar Nunez is
gay in a misguided attempt to prove how
tolerant he is this happens
Oh according to Nunez however the script
only called for Carell to hug him he
told the a/v Club we were just supposed
to hug and he kept hugging me and that
particular take he came in really close
and I'm like where is he going with this